ben écoute et on va voir justement ce
que vous seriez prête à faire ou pas par
amour parce que c'est important que les
français soit au courant ça s'appelle
l'interview par amour et vous savez que
dans la bouche
[Musique]
on a beau chemin pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
il ya deux connards de rebelles ce soir
heureusement que le cadreur et
d'affichettes et qui bouge la caméra
parce que donc par amour est ce que vous
seriez prête à sacrifier vos ambitions
professionnelles
pour l'amour le vrai vous y croyez
toujours vrai amour
heureusement heureusement
si nabil de répondant madame la baronne
de répondre alors ok est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à refuser un
film avec steven spielberg
bien sûr pour l'amour pour tous pour
votre fiancée vous dis je refuse que tu
tournes avec
vous et c'est exactement la théorie de
madame la baronne qui dit quand on aime
quelqu'un on le laisse être on a de la
chance ce soir les deux femmes très très
compréhensible j'espère que les autres
en prendront intelligent intelligent
site où vous avez raison en baronne
est ce que par amour vous retourneriez
vivre en république tchèque
on sent toute la technologie
je crois que si on trouve l'amour et
nous ramène en bout du monde d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire refaire les seins
juste non ce ne sera pas un mot encore
fait pas un vrai amour un type qui
demanderait une peur du goba se faire
refaire les seins ce sera le connard
devrait pas un vrai amour est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à ne pas faire
d'enfant
ça c'est difficile difficile à un mec
qui vous dit je t'aime on se marie mais
moi je déteste les enfants j'en veux pas
c'est pas possible c'est lé fruit de
l'amour c'est automatique c'est naturel
que ça vienne est-ce que par amour vous
aideriez votre votre homme a caché le
corps de quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer à
et vous aussi oui mais vous préférez
mais oui après j'ai écrit un livre
là-dessus
l'avantagé la littérature
c'est tout semble avoir un sens
subitement alors ça c'est une question
importante c'est la question de clotilde
courau clotilde courau qui est une jeune
actrice très talentueuse d'ailleurs nous
a dit que par amour quand elle était
plus jeune elle embrasse et 100 fois de
suite les chaussettes sales de son
fiancé c'est possible vous le feriez
vous
voici à vous non non non non des limites
vous avez jamais vu que c'est pas le
pire faut dire à madine vous avez jamais
vécu et que le batteur de bonnes je dis
en
mon nom avec boris bien ouais c'est vrai
nom nadine
vais avoir 25 ans j'en avais 16 des 20
years ago va s que par amour vous
accepteriez que votre fiancée et une
maîtresse
j'aurais mal à supporter j'aurais
j'aurais très mal
mais si vous voulez mais vraiment
voulais qu'il soit heureux
mais c'est d'éduquer
l'habitude c'est compliqué 6 il amène sa
maîtresse et que vous faites un truc à 3
à st pas lasser mais ça c'est pas besoin
d'être assistées après ce n'est pas sur
le point d'être
légaux elle n'a pas besoin d'être
assistés à son âge était
bon oui mais un peu comme ça quand même
un usager lallaing
c'est pas les déchets après derrick en
banque et singer nous dit c'est pas non
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à aller dans une boîte échangiste tous
les samedis soirs à
on
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
on y va ce soir c'est pas non c'est
non non un samedi sur deux à un samedi
sur deux
tous les 15 jours parce que j'ai pensé à
l'amour et si je n'ai vraiment qu est-ce
qui ça ça apporte le mec fait ce qu'il
veut c'est la groupe il sait pas
vraiment mais c'est en fait c'est sans
fin de fontanes c'est que là une partie
de cet homme je sait pas assez mais non
ça me plairait pas à casser ou c4
conscience là quand même hein est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle
ressentir font quand même
[Musique]
hallucinant cet homme qui rit à 10 ans
qui arrive à imposer comme son tiers des
trucs de malade les cinq mois il faut
savoir ses démons est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à grossir de
10 kg ha ouais si le type aime bien les
rubens les formes vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes vous par amour aussi de 10
kilos ça s'appelle tomber enceinte
et goma et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu